Mucha gente a la de que vivimos mundo
donde la gente lo único que le importa
el dinero landeta obsession a con su s
tattoos sociales an obsession aa con sus
carros ropa su expression iam Dan Xia
esto sobre comparsa uno con el otro y de
sitios Tomas porque tengo mess perfecto
sabemos que no no Heba an inn lado sino
a smashing Masseria Seco Logica
emotional lo que necesitamos mo está de
conciencia expand IDO lo que necesitamos
UN oveja perspectiva una nueva forma de
ver el mundo una nueva forma de ver al
otro a hablando de expand deer estrus
Fronteras expand deer los intros por los
cuales vemos la realidad
expand e de Allison Arlo's para metros
de lo posible right it's all bad again
promoting ways of seeing the world
better more tolerant of individual
differences in which we celebrate what
normally used to be a source of
hostility right liver the it becomes a
question of how to create upgrades for
our culture how to create media that can
act as an inception that can change
people's consciousness broaden their
perspectives expand their horizons you
know and I don't mean to sound like a
bumper sticker but the cliche sometimes
is true right minds are like parachutes
they only function when open whereas
meant a song como para que de solamente
funciona si lo a brace entonces por ahi
esta el camino' question are
Dogma sagir seguir adelante no importa
que obstacle Austin Stig ahmo's yo firma
tear no permitir que nano Dex mo TV
don't let anything take away our
motivation
emancipate ourselves from our misery and
create new forms of bliss for our selves